ccsd bus drivers speaking out telling us
they are fearful after two of the
district's bus drivers were attacked
last week in two separate incidents
victoria saha spoke with two drivers who
share the same concerns and want better
protection victoria
yeah these drivers tell me they're just
doing the job for the students so they
can take them to and from school safely
but now they feel like their safety is
being jeopardized by rowdy students and
adults and they want more protection
i spoke with two drivers who wanted to
remain anonymous in fear of losing their
job but both drivers tell me they are
passionate about what they do you want
to come to work and do your job and go
home to your family we're just doing our
job and the best we can and trying to a
lot of us work
double shoot double routes but safety
has always been a big concern and last
week's violent attacks on the two
drivers are making them reflect on the
close calls they've had it shocks me
that it happens
but it doesn't surprise me been
threatened with violence by parents i
miss their parent and they try to chase
me down in their car to every stop
before the new school year started ccsd
invested in a 6 million dollar project
to install nine cameras in each school
bus but drivers say cameras do not stop
attacks it just records them what good
are cameras it protects us so that they
see what we're saying is the truth not
only are they worried about aggressive
parents but rowdy students the first
thing we do is look into our rearview
mirror the student mirror and and that
takes our eyes off the road and they
believe the students don't face any
consequences from the district they just
tell us keep on driving and the kids sat
down then
rolled to the next school leading them
to believe if a student can get away
with it then a parent could as well
another concern is wanting more help on
the bus such as a school age so the
driver can strictly focus on driving i
sent these concerns to the school
district and while officials did not
specifically address them they did say
in part ccsd will not tolerate any
violence against its employees ccsd
police worked quickly to make an arrest
of an individual involved in one of the
incidents and continues to investigate
the second incident we expect students
to abide by a high standard and adults
whether parents or guardians must set
better examples for their children
victoria saha 8 news now thank you
victoria
46-year-old otis tanner was arrested for
the attack on one of the bus drivers
ccsd reports multiple people attacked
the other no arrests reported yet for
that